on connaissait le speed dating le job
dating voilà le fameux dating
ici on n'est pas là pour trouver l'amour
mais bien un projet de vie autour de
l'agriculture un métier passion qui
souffre d'une moyenne d'âge élevée plus
de 50 % des exploitants ont plus de 50
ans et chaque année ils sont 150 à
partir à la retraite
la chambre de l'agriculture de l'indre
qui a eu cette idée de rencontres tire
la sonnette d alarme
le leitmotiv c'est renouveler les
générations aujourd'hui deux exploitants
et demi alors le demi c'est difficile à
le matérialiser partent en retraite
quand tu as une personne s'installe donc
sur les territoires il faut absolument
mettre tout en oeuvre pour que pour
inverser ces sites ou au moins les
contenir top chrono les agriculteurs ont
sept minutes pas une de plus pour faire
connaissance et voir si leurs objectifs
peuvent être compatibles
bref voir si ça match ce que j'ai envie
d'aller danser dans une voie là c'est
toujours une bonne expérience et je
pensais pour le professionnel aussi que
cherche des jeunes donc en envoyant sa
doit être confortée dans l'esprit
c'était un jeune je raconte dans
l'élevage une passe du temps donc on est
noir au delà de
de retransmettre quelque chose de
financiers transmettre une passion quand
même les machines passion ce rendez vous
est un succès si bien qu'une deuxième
session aura lieu en novembre prochain
pour participer il faut s'inscrire
auprès de la chambre d'agriculture de
l'indre